if you haven't played Metal Gear Solid 5  yet you're in luck the best way to play  it hit store shelves soon I'm Tony and  this is your definitive game spot news  update Metal Gear Solid 5 the definitive  experience contains ground zeroes and  the phantom pain plus all of their  previously released DLC that means  you're getting the deja vu and Jame vu  missions for ground zero plus all the  weapons and costumes and items for  phantom pain Metal Gear Online expansion  packs and add-ons are also included this  edition was leaked by more than a few  retailers recently so it's good to get  the official announcement the mgs 5  definitive experience is coming to ps4  Xbox one and PC on October 11th in the  US October 13th  in the UK it'll cost you 50 bucks on  console but Konami has not yet confirmed  the content and pricing of the Steam  version for PC for all the biggest news  from Konami you're already in the right  place  you